hey every day even Tamara back again in
the world of Hyrule we had a nice
adventure you know even Clyde Island how
can we go release now the DLCs out we're
going to attempt the Master Sword trials
burning out one life one life I've given
it a couple of tries and I've died a lot
unlike room 6 or 7 yeah I would like to
finish the first run of flaws yeah so if
you can get I think you can either get
beyond 6 & 7 which seems to be your
roadblock right now that's my personal
best and get your personal best yeah any
higher is a bonus for us but one life
left one-line life only is still a
challenge well I'm gonna I'm going to
prepare like we did a tips video on the
master sword trials that you can go and
watch if you're struggling like me that
might help but one thing that I've
noticed is that you take these stat
buffs in with you yeah so if I but not
the items not the items yeah
if I eat like an attack up this one
gives me a minutes if I eat that
I will keep my extra hearts I'll keep
that attack up so that might give me an
edge that means when you got eight
minutes to play with yeah but we'll see
so you're going to be super-powered for
eight minutes after that I don't know if
I can get very fine a minute yeah you
can make a thirty minute
attack up potion using three mighty
bananas a dragon horn some lighting this
or something is yeah so that's probably
the best way to go about yeah I don't
have the ingredients are just like
anything to fine
there's basically wave-based combat yeah
from room to room that well it's a bit
different from what people like normally
assume waves which you imagine clear
having at you I think things like gears
before kind of template that expectation
each room will be a little bit different
will have its own challenges like some
of have water in them some have like a
lot of vertical combat so use fortify
your mind body and soul all three of
those there is an element of trial and
error in this version of the master
trolls as they call the wave based
combat yeah you can come back a bunch of
time to figure out the kind of like the
best case and scenarios and strategies
for each of these rooms they don't
change each time you return right know
they're the same so like that's what
I've done enough I know that if I took a
bomb over there I'll be able to get a
few goblins while they go for weapon
yeah like I try to conserve my weapons
as much as I can of the early ways by
using bombs yeah done easy has does room
one one room one happy boys I'm done
because obviously like you see you lose
all of your items you should really
scavenge yes you can this isn't even
honor there's like forty five forty five
rooms total floors total should I say
and this isn't even on the new hardware
yeah these are the beginning twelve so
it says on the bomber like here we go
I didn't get the sound of alarm oh wow
that was pretty good
how dodge though so you've got to use
your either you keep your cheeks late
that is extremely useful yeah bad throat
you're doing climb the street Oh
Oh close man you are all dear I can't
give I sent a medium bye
I have to have many weapons no oh dear
you hurry that me you love to try to get
him out is that where my boys gone
killed my friends we're just trying to
use the Bombers emotional atmosphere
I've got one axe now I need to go and
find that am travellers sword or
whatever Cobbins head floor 3 out of 45
now 45 settle in friends I think after
you do all 45 is when your master sword
is like double toilet rank yeah we take
that into the main game yeah so it can
be worth it
I feel like if you haven't finished the
main quest it's like a perfect time to
do it I hate killing reasons they're
adorable
it's down beside rise
I'm gonna I'm going to leave that one
alive and you'll see what Ison case
no no no no no no no no I need to fire
this class
you stay away or is it where is it now I
need that chest
there's one over there as well is the
benefit of repeat playthroughs you know
where things are
Rob handler and bless his soul here he
played it before I did because he p
massive zelda fan so he was on it like
immediately and he was like he would
give me a couple of hints he said are
these chests on the floor can see them
like we said we have a Clips video on
our YouTube page so head over to
gamespot.com hold slash [ __ ] YouTube and
you can gain sakhanka whole YouTube each
of the coal flash in spot yeah and you
can see our video there in which we saw
provide some hot tips for going ahead in
its fall
yeah I'm pretty sure I saw four up in my
[ __ ] oh I think the chest is broke broke
here on the way down I've never seen
that happens with you know are we doing
like a red this is like a relatively
easy wave it's more of a puzzle to get
these little bonus things I think
because the fire arrows can be super
useful another good tip is they only
have raw food in the minute which is
opposite isn't very good for healing but
if you it's all desperate you can set
fire to grasp and do like a quick cook
so they are seared steaks and bare grill
this Bear Grylls yep drink your own
hyrulean wait yes here on everything
right this floor can be a little tricky
if I remember correctly
gotta like be sniper in the grass
that wasn't a headshot that wasn't a
headshot well well alright fair enough
yeah there's a dude up there but as you
climb up this he's already on the move
you know he'll you'll see it the guys on
this trail see if you climb that hmm the
pack our team tactfully those forms oh
poor guy give me that blue koblan salute
the gray ones the black ones at the most
powerful Noble is white ones as well
good throw may I've got them I've got em
ups NBA Jam next time featuring I think
there is my fam this is something you
can do it's real treat yeah but if you
just stand here and let em shoot arrows
at you if you can name all the arrows
are stuck in your shield do you collect
them yeah nice
sneaky cheeky this is also a good
stratagem OOP again but there will also
be they will be looting here no it's
going on mate why must we pushes it off
themselves they can sometimes break them
open for you
[ __ ] it it's like a desires in here
thank you look at me no ah bugger this
last act of defiance taking away that
sword ready gun that's pretty good hold
yeah not too bad
well wearing a bomb like a half okay I
was worried that I lost that then yeah
oh no that's wrong game water real real
I like how that's the compiled language
of gaming now long ladder equals Metal
Gear no I press the wrong button then
you go Circle it oh yeah oh yeah well
it's having this ladder great words Gary
good near you if you hit the vault that
bolded the barrels full damage finish -
ah I've got up that ladder before word I
just started hitting the Goblin smashed
a barrel and just gone all the way to
the moon and back my favorite thing
about it is the ending jingle plays the
like a boxing ding ding ding ding
that didn't work
oh well yeah that I'm that's full of
okay they both come now you know I need
one to stay over there so I can
one-on-one scrub on anyone you scrub
listen ripoff I didn't mean to I pray
this money no do one life careful it's a
good strategy
all right one more cobbling I'm Wambach
hablen hey that was quick as rude you
got this
this one's all right one there we go son
Oh where's the other Makabe we go at
lead or killed in the explosion did he
yeah I thought you just got a set on
fire right away no I went way better
than I thought it was going to you to be
honest all right here we go
you know these you know me still the
same og
but I'm all these golem
oh hey don't don't don't don't don't
stand under it don't stand under it
don't stand under it don't stand
are you crazy right now are the glance
things like a jab from Mike Tyson there
there we go run again of its renown
sometimes as boss it's like some of the
glancing blows won't actually yeah you
know think guy they're not waste any
time in this to you something big a lot
more I am still I'm still I'm still
understood in the main game there's some
stone calluses that have the rock on its
back so you can barely even his it this
is a straight up Shadow of the Colossus
that's just a tiny version Oh genetical
after nearly no egos
that's what you need that's what you
need that you need oh it's got that quit
all right
good timing on that explosion I didn't
actually explore as level this is it
it's Mike it's s I've got okay James
lockers on boxes on boxes Thanks what
was in them though was there anything in
them
disappointment that's what was in them
there has to be something in unknown
they were just put them there for a
giggle or a trick are you kidding me
go to work Nintendo honestly just
thought they'd just been as a barrel
over here sometime why don't you just
got that they're just scattered into the
ether right yeah I think this is as far
as I've got I know it's a level after
this guy in the middle you get like this
kind of checkpoint where you can
actually take a breather do some cooking
get your head head on straight and
everything's okay she'll love the mines
I here with a few weapon key to life
Aoife got myself an eight full blade
it's actually a fairy over there it's
going to have that mate let us all be my
on our wait wait you have to be sneaky
don't you oh i bested a knight without
even without counted two on one life
charge the instrument is the new line
line cosa I ensure this is hologram fish
get into fresh fruit just dumped in a
pot hit him up shove them in down here
shorts slimy live angry at myself that I
Biff that ferry get Harvey that the
world be mended Carboni when is that
fair though my brain will be blinded
like a run for it
grab it and I was like no wait cuz they
just
run away explain Kabakov that this is
the last area I've been in let's rough a
lot of stable ground her there's our
foes live great camouflage roads going
continue breathing well well he seems
tough up left it should be very quiet
we're hunting wabbits the hunting live a
little
was that nice who shot me the head you
want me don't know if that big green
bugger it's going to be close enough
really explode if you're shootin yeah
but I don't if he's going to be close
enough to a do it hit the man's do it is
this
that's the chest mate even though they
might try and agro them so they come
over here yeah boys get your weapons
come this way or it was a delayed there
was a delay to Italy there was a
deafening and then you got two of them
worth oh nice Arnaud our boomerang
exhausted see the picture run away it's
my fish got stuck
oh oh that was a bad one cause if I
touch there it is
that's what I wanted you know
they stock BAM
ciao ciao there is so we needed just go
boys let's go Oscar just yet
deafening our chest no chest voice
lesson bass may as well cut lads is raw
for the face is raw you have to cut them
now that's Gordon Ramsay meme yeah
top time Golden Rose earring or can i
serous no I mean it's good yeah it's
good but it's not quite right I can't
imagine me doing for 45 rooms of this
yeah I reckon it probably wizard maja
goodbye oh this is already weird
I miss that the night there you go I'm
not a fan of these wizard boys wizard
loves I'm going to need doesn't work
get closer we're going to be really
precise it's not a metal one where is it
just is it just on the ground that I'm
an idiot no sign around it floats to
wooden chests you linked behavior stuff
right get your boxers on there is their
hero what's it in that must be why I did
a chest broke this minute I wouldn't
alright yeah I'll take some arrows
tomorrow that where's the wizard gone
prancing around on the water they really
creeped me out the way they wave at you
and they see you stop that
oh I can't get means in the drink talk
about come over here so I can actually
move you Oh got the water though
Marn I'm in the water
oh no I'll use electricity type like you
the Pokemon hey yeah what's that would
you there uncle you're miss sort of in
costly but knock them over
I can't even drop it gap here on that
lightning rod can you grab it using my
razor I can grab it anywhere I just need
I have inventory just full first time
I've had an inventory for the weapons
when you come to this DLC like if you've
got fair inventory space makes it quite
challenging
alright imagine yeah true Dolph Anna
what's going on over here yeah it's
calls for then you summarize that
yep yep then running both oh of juice me
so much damn good look
oh yes boy I should maybe a few that
first time saw some Metroid on the floor
there lose my mind lost over whenever
they met yeah stupid me what such dumb
paper
there's our foes I can't help it we did
what you doing
oh really done with that not breaking
together we've got them all of it yes oh
wow
solid singing really do those Marilyn up
on you
one down in the water
this music is verse yes
take that so shuttle upon you what so
color at Soul Calibur enemy was out
there that's lizard man and you're a
chemical man she loves soul calibur oh
why you know this again but no but hold
up while I shove my face full of its
random bits of food
aaaa well nice fair enough can't come
folder just slip out brightening there
nice care of it yeah a scrub does our
closer actually we're soon as they start
spitting hot water I mean what is going
on here
Oh give it a boat give it up oh that's
not how about something a little you
like slices over there and stuff I won't
see me right let's go he's looking
directly at you
well because here I'm nineteen fire
arrows too close fit low oh no you will
tell you a tingle is on fire oh it's not
loud not yeah it's lit its lit I'm not a
fan of it you know hey hey
are you I just have to stay on this boat
I'm sure stares at you for trying take
out as many as you can before hand oh
did more damage in the hey you still
alive
fire is a little cover now nice there is
there it goes now I'd know I don't know
what awaiting me on the bloody platform
it's gone there no no I am the naught
you can stay in the war house from this
guy's a little help
he's a red one is awesome abort no no no
no
Cobbins can't swim but college guys let
you kick it Oh sick
it's your shine you can go to drink no
it's not 0:01 life only it's over hey
you know where you come from he wants me
to hang out upstairs what's all the
commotion down there all right we've got
a bomb bleep going oh my god can you
believe this
get away or get rid this guy myself okay
he drowned he drowned it was worth it
he's gone he's dead
in your defensive up defense is that
that's probably why that bomb didn't see
you as much damage I've got ammo
cobbling to worry about now where is he
is that what these are they're nice
chillin out there yeah there is yes get
away go away Galvin you know lucky
follows Gary more enemies that I'd like
nothing to this me more rooms is eight
yeah where are we in this Oh
is a 10 don't notice 1212
all right well guess doesn't get to
tenon remember the pallava we had
fighting one of these oh yes he's in
title and these guys took all our
ingenuity tequila what is my most
alright I'd try something my god
this guy's got arm on his feet he's got
honesty oh well he's gonna stop you he
did it well he did it while you went
wrong
no cuz maybe I did a good bit of damage
I did go a bit goodbye John damage No
he's going to get a tree he's going to
pick up the trees
yes put your tree down a bit boa though
yeah yeah and a sword this when he
starts shield his eye
for me singing yeah it can keep him
there he might just keep kinetic of the
earth at one point there you start
shielding his eyes they should be now
wait
[ __ ] your tree fat man have a blob in
that tree oh wait what about fires
shooting a ball bag with the fires
he's like why that's why have you done
this right spicy Wiener I'll sleep on
fruit I'm stunned a melon or just be
like really quick I was a really slow
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait there
you go that's the strap I've got
overloaded
no weapons there mates
[Music]
you're done it's done son just slice
your toes just in time for your
difference to run out it has to be the
last level this floor right surely it
can't get one more than it to the first
first run where we had dough it's gonna
be V but no it's just the GG son you get
in there power up
I wonder of each one of these platforms
is where you have to go between yeah
commend your efforts in this trial
hi fam my via though fall off now into
the abyss yeah that's how we die our God
you might reckon it make you start again
if you actually actually I was sure
they're not last time I pulled the
master sword out was thrown I wasn't
wearing my pants
let's go again middle trials I guess so
you get me play-doh me your throws is
cool if you want to do that skip all
this just plop in the pack their power
swords the Space Marine thing the Master
Sword back in the pedestal I mean I hope
it's different rooms yeah I think it
will be I'd be a bit it's a cop-out if
not I reckon oh yes totems Oh
Wow
feels bit naughty I believe another
weapon oh here comes lay are you okay
wind when you take it in no way Lowe's
didn't give me nothing all you jerk I
can throw this over I reckon my band on
you mmm yeah give me mine a review about
ash man 30 diet okay we good we all
right you're right we're good we got
this just entered in all 45 right now
Oh Oh the boys Oh got a boat you glid
some of you over there my boat oh god be
able on HS
there's a boat he's got ona you gotta
Bowl
give us your bowl give me give it to
between there we go
sauce me get a falling damage
Oh No that's it you get out of here mate
okay just
when we friend of many that that's all I
don't want normal Arizona waste my ass
fire as well where was that chef there's
another one these just man's the Wizards
into the fear this mate love you
oh yeah well I don't know
Saturday night the wine saloon novel is
it flowing about hi some problem boys
i : okay you know what
let's go nuts my gonna hold hold why to
win Dixie down a miserable time yes it
was at this moment on you record scratch
free interim via yes this is me slipper
koplan I'm probably wondering how I got
myself into this big delicious dish
where's yeah as
that's it move nails good smell out
right now one from the it's called the
flap these are all like windy themed
[Music]
it's good though as you make quick
getaways true
I popped that bomb do you mean no the
thing
wait is that you dropping bombs yeah
they do that it's Indiana I just pressed
I just plop it out this isn't it fluffy
no you do that either did I mean working
tender the bombs are quite a feat but
you know what it to let you off oh wow
don't know how much that is I wanted to
ring it off the click this one you're
probably wondering that was fog as the
air gave a most the rush to me so I
missed time the jump
can you tell me walk over there because
this SIG flip don't pick it up with my
nan Gavin don't eat you double when sky
firing
series oh you want me it doesn't even
see that cruising around it
oh yeah yeah yeah no I didn't see it
attack animation because those little it
away that's pretty good for one life
yeah so bad I reckon Oh
the wall I bet it sees around in a
six-block shooting people with eyes are
illegal I hire I can people in the
conversation have already be in a movie
yeah let us know the conversation what
your personal best is I'm not going to
try and be it because that's fully as
best I can do
yeah if you liked the video hit the like
button to join all the references it's
great easier for easy reference if
you're too young to know who easy is
also like the video subscribe check out
our tips video we mentioned and we will
see you next time
stressful man that always very stressful